I think
in the skateboarding culture you get a
lot of people in general that are
different we were just kids that want to
play someone being in their own place
and do everybody else's dream
Chris Worley is the founder of a skate a
nonprofit that teaches kids with autism
how to skateboard
autism has a lot of aspects to it most
of the kids need occupational therapy of
some form skateboarding is similar to
other therapies they're learning how to
control our body in motion and it just
stimulates parts of the brain that you
need to be stimulated in order to do
things in life in order to have
conversations in order to pay attention
I have a son who will soon be 14 his
name is Sasha and he was diagnosed with
autism at 22 months old I bought him his
first skateboard when he was right at
five years old his brother was three it
was really difficult for them to just
come together and play there was no play
somehow the movement of the skateboard
just made him focused and they would
just skate and I want to do that for
other families Chris started a skate
eight years ago in a church parking lot
in Birmingham Alabama it's since
expanded across the US and
internationally this year they were
invited to participate in the Dew Tour a
pro skating contest in California where
kids were paired with professional
skateboarders I've known Sasha since I
got involved at a skate about five years
ago the joy that I see that it brings
kids like that's where I know that this
what I'm supposed to be doing the
skateboarding culture is accepting of
everyone in our spectrum or not spectrum
no one cares what color type gender
whatever it is like if you can skate you
can stay and we got love for you it's
really incredible to see kids change
through our program I see families just
see their child who is now capable of
something
and they didn't know it in a way forming
a skate is like a love letter to Sasha
you may never understand that or know I
have what I do